so my name is Kip audience on I'm a
mechanical engineer from Copenhagen
visiting the nobel museum as a tourist
today I'd like to ask a question of
forwards it's a universe hoped thank you
I can you're asking is the universe
curved the answer is yes in four
dimensions Einstein showed us that in
four dimensions space and time are
curved by the action of gravitation
which comes from the presence of mass or
mass and energy and so yes in four
dimensions the universe is curved but if
you would take the three-dimensional
slice of the universe where all of the
space that you're thinking about is the
same time after the Big Bang then that
space that three-dimensional space is
flat in other words in that space the
sum of the angles of the triangle is 180
degrees it's a bit of a surprise but a
wonderful discovery of very recent
measurements that we were able to answer
your question that way